beruf das stichwort new york ist möchte
über einen politiker rechnen war ich den
wind nicht wechselt aber ich bin an
gericht war also ich will ja nicht nur
übereinander sprechen das sind 2 im
spiel ist also die liberalen nur die
grünen streiten darum wer den
finanzminister stellen darf ist dass
christian lindner fdp chef oder ist dass
robert habeck von den grünen ich finde
das verwunderlich also die
begehrlichkeit der grünen finde ich
geradezu beats haben jeder hat erlebt
dass bei den sondierungsgesprächen der
neuen koalition die fdp die pflöcke in
der finanzpolitik eingeräumt hat und
zwar ausschließlich keine
steuererhöhungen schuldenbremse bleibt
plus anderes das sind die wesentlichen
festlegung da haben die anderen mit den
zähnen geknirscht aber die fdp konnte
sich durchsetzen weil das ihr
lebenselexier ist jedenfalls in dieser
koalition
und da gibt es einen guten grund für das
dann der vorsitzender dieser partei das
ministeramt übernimmt um darauf zu
achten dass das umgesetzt wird und nicht
im laufe der jahre zerfällt die fdp ist
da ein gebranntes kind 2009 als die
schwarz gelbe koalition gegründet wurde
hat die fdp eine reihe von
steuerreform vor haben in die
koalitionsvereinbarung reingeschrieben
guido westerwelle hat sich aber
entschlossen außenminister zu werden
dann wurde wolfgang schäuble
finanzminister der hat das alles kühl
zur seite geschoben hat nichts davon
verwirklicht und hat gesagt da ist die
zeit darüber hinweggegangen eigentlich
hätte da schon die fdp die koalition
verlassen müssen weil sie war auf null
reduziert ich habe den eindruck dass die
grünen heute deshalb so großen wert
darauf legen weil sie eine
verhandlungsposition aufbauen wollen für
ihr klimaschutz ministerium diesen
ministerium nämlich ein vetorecht zu
verschaffen wie es das finanzministerium
auch hat bisher hat das nur das
finanzministerium dieses vetorecht
also das hieße dann dass klimaschutz
ministerium bei projekten anderer
ministerien
abblocken kann weil wir schlecht für für
für den klimaschutz sind dagegen habe
ich nix wenn dich völlig in ordnung weil
klimaschutz wichtig genug ist und dann
sollen sie eben zwei ministerien haben
die das in anspruch nehmen können das
geld auch eine gewisse ausgewogenheit
die spd den kanzler die beiden anderen
haben ein sehr wichtiges ministerium
jedenfalls glaube ich dass christian
gentner anspruch aufs finanzministerium
hat und wenn in der fdp wäre würde ich
sagen das ist sogar die koalitionsfrage
hier also christian liter muss anspruch
haben auf das finanzministerium denn die
grünen lieben ja sowas so koordinierung
ministerien mit vetorecht ja eigentlich
das allererste wahl dieses berühmte
bundesministerium für verbraucherschutz
energie und landwirtschaft geführt
damals von renate künast stande kommen
nach einem großen agra skandal dass so
eine ähnliche funktion hatte also diese
querschnittsaufgaben da kann man braucht
man gar nicht so viele ministerien
bekommen alles mit blockiert und zwei
solcher blockade ich nenne es mal oder
koordinierungs ministerien wäre
natürlich zu viel in einer hand aber es
ist natürlich aus einem anderen grunde
auch noch richtig weil robert habeck hat
ja gesagt wie er sich die welt vorstellt
50 milliarden jedes jahr für zehn jahre
für den klima innovations- packt das wir
haben bis heute eigentlich und sagt na
ja das kann man doch ganz einfach machen
weil wir kriegen ja noch geld zurück
wenn wir geld aufnehmen also als würden
wir jetzt eine million aufnehmen und
kriegten dann auch 10.000 euro zurück in
wahrheit müssen wir natürlich das geld
zahlen zurückzahlen und haben wenn der
entsprechende schuldner noch sind
vielleicht 10.000 euro nachlass letzter
punkt ganz interessant heute ein
interview mit ich glaube das war auch an
der replik von christian lindner darauf
von frau berbalk total untergegangen im
deutschlandfunk der sagt sie so zum
letzten drittel ja der soli da geht
nicht weg nur das haben wir so
vereinbart hat kein mensch wird man
sieht ja das ist ja immer wir reden
nicht über inhalte also kein mensch hat
es beschlossen aber jetzt schon mal raus
gibt bleibt deswegen glaube ich von
christian lindner das war eine replik
darauf als sie als indiskretion oder
vielleicht sogar als machtposition noch
aus gebracht hat und hat gesagt freunde
mir nicht ich werde das und deswegen
haben wir uns ist ganz egal
was denken sie muss christian lindner
zugreifen dürfen dürfen die grünen nicht
sagen begonnen die grünen dürfen
theoretisch alles sagen aber dass ich
jetzt als hier nicht der meinung bin
dass christian da kein guter
finanzminister wäre das ist glaube ich
und fraglich ich habe nur ein problem
mit dieser diskussion über diese
vetorechte
den sie haben zu recht eine
vergangenheit angesprochen es gibt auch
noch bevor vergangenheit quasi die
anderen sondierungen um jamaika und ich
möchte eben nicht denn mir ist es
wirklich wichtig dass wir da eine
zukunfts koalition hinbekommen dass wir
eigentlich jetzt bevor irgend ein
verhandlungsteam abseits der führung
miteinander gesprochen hat schon
diskutieren ja wo universal vetos
bekommt also ich rieche da natürlich
leider diese spirit ich verstehe diese
gesagt die fdp hat gesagt sie will das
finanzministerium die grünen haben
gesagt sie wollen klimaministerium plus
wedhorn ich fand einen und einfärben
oder du hast ein interview angesprochen
ich habe im interview gehört mit oder
gesehen mit richard david precht der
begründet haben warum ist der lindner
wenn vorher
deswegen werde ich nutzen eines total
lacht also ja ich hatte doch recht bei
dem maler christian lindner also seine
großen stärken seien das ja nicht
unbedingt sich im april zu vertiefen bis
3 uhr früh sondern die super reden zu
halten irgendwie die großen linien
rauszuhauen und im finanzministerium hat
er doch da gar nicht so viele
möglichkeiten da saßen vor so langweiler
wie olaf scholz und peer steinbrück und
noch ganz viele andere und warum das
ministerium war noch warum nicht einfach
immer auf den putz hauen kann und sagen
kann so machen wir es und
finanzministerium ist doch eher
langweilig oder also erstmal würde ich
die these stützen dass das ziemlich
flach ist bei christian lindner und
definitiv super fit indem ist und sogar
auf dem parkett übrigens wunderschön
nacht zuvor ordnern und natürlich ist
dass man auch nicht
arbeiten und nachts katja immer da in
die ordner und bin schon ganz schön dass
christian lendner und das eine wenigen
politiker in deutschland immer
vorbereiten das kann ich ein bisschen
mit bilder anderer vielleicht auch mal
trocken und doch gehört
und ich möchte gerne meine sequenz sehen
da könnte ich von habe es übrigens
mehrere aufzeigen wo christian lender
nicht vor
es ist doch einfacher zuschüsse
oppositionsführer zu sein und ein
bisserl was zu corona sagen und ein
bisschen hier ein bisschen da oder durch
den großen haushalt zu gehen also ist es
übrigens nicht wenn man sich die
leistung von herrn brinkhaus härter das
war nämlich genau so flach wie das ist
ja lindner nicht gut ist in der man gut
reden insofern traue ich ihm das
wirklich an der stelle absolut zu den
punkt den ich machen wollte ist ich
glaube eben nicht dass diese weder
diskussion so spannend wie die ist so
richtig wie die ist dass die an die
stelle des hingehört ist
ja es ist ein
historisches hause ganze hand ja wohl
nicht geglaubt hat er könne über die
finanzpolitik selber quasi weltpolitik
machen und alle auch den bundeskanzler
den damaligen regulieren das war oskar
lafontaine er hat geglaubt wenn ich
erstmal finanzminister bin dann esse ich
wo meine partei lang zu gehen hat hier
auch andere brücken glaubte und macht
dann international sowieso alles klar
das erste aufwachen kam als er nach
washington kam und der dortige
finanzminister ihn erst mal hat ein
halbe stunde warten lassen und es ging
so weiter weil man das ethos schröder
organisiert hat das als seine thesen
dann doch nicht so hielt und das ist
natürlich auch wenn wir immer jetzt
lesen von den angeblich drei köchen den
drei quasi kanzler die da sind nicht
weil die show nicht der agrar und sich
natürlich einig sind wir zwei zusammen
habe klingt da wir sind stärker als der
mann im kanzleramt wenn wir alles auf
die waage bringen trotzdem es gibt einen
im kanzleramt der die
richtlinienkompetenz und der ist im
zweifel auch stärker also mit dem vito
ist das ja so eine sache das sollte man
nicht überschätzen ich will noch eine
frage die mein letzter satz lautete das
muss für die sg fdp die koalitionsfrage
sein sehen sie das so wenn das
ministerium nicht krieg gehen sie nicht
in die regierung wir haben uns nicht so
viel mühe und zeit gegeben dann papier
das einen weg aufzeigt zu produzieren um
dann einen tag danach irgendwelche
linien an der stelle aus was ist ihre
meinung meine meinung ist dass wir uns
in den teams zusammensetzen und schauen
was wir fürs land raus alles nehmen was
geht nur wenn der postmann nein nein
aber ich bin wirklich tief überzeugt
dass dieses bin dass wir aufschreiben
was wir nicht gefällt was wir gerne
hätte es nicht funktioniert ich komme
aus einem bundesland das hat eine ampel
um malu dreyer ist eine sehr
intelligente und kluge regierungschefin
und die hat das eben in einer art und
weise moderiert dass das geklappt hat
und übrigens bestätigt wurde aber nicht
nicht haben wolle der fdp habe als
millionen das erlebt und ich möchte das
nicht weil es mir wirklich darum ja mit
der erste der überhaupt gesagt hat
welches ministerium er will war
christian lindner weil es ihm so wichtig
sein er hat ja recht die fdp kann doch
ihre ganze existenzberechtigung in
dieser entstehenden koalition nur
begründen damit dass sie für
finanzpolitische solidität
tritt und den beiden linken parteien
eben in den arm fällt wenn die geld
ausgeben wollen natürlich steuer erhöhen
wollen sonst gibt es keinen grund für
die fdp die koalition zu gehen und wenn
das nicht möglich ist wenn der das
ministerium nicht kriegt fangen die
sofort an geld zu verpulvern jeder wenn
du noch mal fragen gibt's den soli jetzt
oder ist der soli der soli wird wenn
dann vom verfassungsgericht weg eger
aber nicht von der regierung
[Musik]